حلقه جديده من حرب التصريحات الامريكيه
الروسيه لكنها تتجه هذه المره الى التشكيك
في قدرات الجيش الروسي الذي لطالما وصفه
الكرملين بانه ثاني اقوى الجيوش في العالم
ليس الكريم للفحسب فهذه الروايه اكدها
مؤشر جلوبال فاير باور المعني بتصنيف
الجيوش الاكثر قوه
[موسيقى]
لكن لوزير الخارجيه الامريكي راي اخر حول
هذا التصنيف
ليصنف الجيش الروسي بانه ثاني اقوى جيش
لكن ليس في العالم بل في اوكرانيا وحدها
معتبرا ان جهود بوتين على مدى عقدين باءت
بالفشل
لهذا
غالبا ما ادعى بان لديه ثاني اقوى جيش في
العالم وصدقه الكثيرون اليوم يرى الكثيرون
ان الجيش الروسي هو ثاني اقوى جيش في
اوكرانيا من حيث المعدات والتكنولوجيا
والقياده والقوات واستراتيجيه والتكتيكات
والروح المعنويه
لكن عند الحديث عن الصراع في اوكرانيا
فالمواجهه العسكريه بحسب موسكو لم تكن بين
الجيش الروسي والاوكراني فحسب انما مع حلف
الناتو ايضا وهو ما ورد على لسان امين
مجلس الامن للاتحاد الروسي المقرب من
الرئيس فلاديمير بوتين
الصراع في اوكرانيا يعد مواجهه عسكريه بين
روسيا وحلف شمال الاطلسي فالغرب يسعى
لتقسيم روسيا ومحوها من الخريطه السياسيه
للعالم
العلاقات بين روسيا وحلف الناتو تتجه الى
الاسوا وسط تكرار الاتهامات الروسيه للحلف
بالانخراط اكثر في الصراع الاوكراني سلطان
العيبان العربيه
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات